der syrische schriftsteller vs in zürich
größer könnte der kontrast kaum sein
hier die heile welt dort in der mascus
wo er herkommt tobt ein bürgerkrieg
der blutige wahnsinn des tötens verfolgt
mich bis in den schlaf
es sind alltag und albtraum über nacht
das schrieb haas hat bevor er syrien
verließ vor vier monaten will hertha
drei hühner in der momentanen situation
ist literatur von politik kommt nur von
literatur zu sprechen der referat an dem
was in syrien geschieht und nur über
politik zu sprechen wäre verrat an der
literatur im darm und man muss über
alles sprechen
deshalb reist verwässert nun durch
europa berichtet obwohl er kaum darüber
zu schreiben vermag vom unvorstellbaren
das in syrien geschieht und sein land
zerreißt
schreiben heißt leben aber die
gegenwärtigen umstände lassen mich weder
schreiben noch lesen
keine nachrichtensendung vergeht ohne
dass man sieht wie häuser weg herein
moscheen und kirchen zerstört werden
scharfschützen verschonen weder kinder
noch frauen noch alte menschen bomben
felder felder bäume und 4
solche szenen blockieren jede
inspiration und sie setzen sich so in
den gedanken fest dass man sie beim
nachdenken nicht mehr ausblenden kann
was ich vor meinen augen entfaltet
übertrifft alles was ich mir jemals
hätte vorstellen können
doch von all dem unvorstellbaren
belohnung berichten in syrien zu leben
war lebensgefährlich geworden
jetzt reist er durch europa und wird mit
fragen gelöchert
wohin wird sich die arabische welt
entwickeln nach den revolutionen ist der
aufbruch schon am ende
wir sollten nicht vergessen dass es sich
bei den arabischen gesellschaften
vormals und geschlossene um
verschlossene gesellschaften gehandelt
hat sie sich selbst und ihre probleme
überhaupt nicht kranken durch die
revolutionen sind nun alle diese
probleme offenbar und offensichtlich
geworden mit allen negativen ins
positive drehen
diese gesellschaften lernen im moment
sich selbst kennen
herrschaft komme kein präsidenten kein
billig und gremien zu sondern allein
gottes blutiger himmel
das ist ein roman den er im
literaturhaus zürich präsentiert und mit
dem er das heikelste thema der
arabischen welt berührt den kampf
zwischen religiösen und weltlichen
ideologien und das konfliktreiche ringen
um identität
die hauptfigur des romans sein linker
intellektueller aus damaskus erfährt
dass sein sohn als gotteskrieger in irak
kämpft er lässt sich nach bagdad
einschleusen und beginnt ihn zu suchen
streift durch ein land das sich selbst
zerstört im kleinen krieg
rivalisierender miliz im kampf gegen die
amerikanischen besatzer
er begegnet unvorstellbarer grausamkeit
in den krankenhäusern in den
leichenhallen des irak
die suche wird zur konfrontation mit
sich selbst mit politischen ideen die
verloren gingen mit einer realität in
der politik in der krieg immer öfter
religiös motiviert wird und irgendwann
trifft er seinen sohn der zum führer
einer al-kaida-zelle aufgestiegen ist
der showdown zwischen zwei menschen die
sich nie mehr verstehen werden ist der
höhepunkt dieses romans der ohne zu
werten detailliert schildert wie brutal
der krieg der ideologien der religionen
der kulturen an land zerfleischt
in diesem roman geht es auch darum dass
wir uns um unsere probleme unsere themen
selbst kümmern sollten
wir hatten uns daran gewöhnt dass wir
unsere angelegenheiten in amerikanischen
und westlichen außenministerien
besprochen und behandelt werden
eine folge war eben die amerikanische
invasion im irak
aber was haben wir trotz dieses krieges
trotz der kriegsschiffe in der region
erreicht wir haben den irak in die arme
des iran getreten ein ironisches
ergebnis wie ich finde dass amerika für
den iran den krieg geführt hat und wer
führt für oder gegen willen den krieg in
syrien obwohl verfasser dass roman zu
großen teilen im irak 2006 spielt denkt
man ständig an syriens gegenwart an den
bürgerkrieg die rivalisierenden
konfessionen den blut geschmack der
diktatur die persönlichen tragödien und
wie der westen tatenlos zuschaut
ein roman wie eine prophezeiung ein text
über den zentralen konflikt im innern
arabische gesellschaften